[Music]
up
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this can all be over
all the de-platforming can end
just cry out
that the world health organization
and their merciful messengers as youtube
and twitter
are super
awesome
is super awesome
super awesome
[Music]
just cry out
that youtube has like
been really cool
about all this
[Music]
[Applause]
just saying crowder dear god just say it
come on man
the band comedian
wishes to say a word
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
speedy
oh that is gross that is gross that is
tepidly warm
tea
green tea what does that do now on your
people call is that the i guess i'm
really getting that umami
i made that that mouth feel earthy that
slime earthiness yeah yeah
earthy it's like dirt yeah it tastes
like ectoplasm
all right hey we have a great big story
there's a weird opening we did a four
and a half hour stream yesterday what do
you want from us yeah and then we all
stayed up late
for get your tampax pearls ready big red
wave
big red wave
men can red wave too
[Applause]
so just ask just ask pete buckingham
red wave leave it's a thing only
happened once feeding on this period
come on the nordic countries got it
right
so we have a lot to discuss today and we
also have a package where i went on
location down to a uh an area of color
in dallas i believe i'm using the term
correctly uh and asked them about
vaccines and masks and the answers may
surprise you or if you've been paying
attention not at all
gonna be talking about the election i
like the nut at all yeah yeah we'll be
talking about the elections that have
been going on too close to call some of
them right as opposed to arizona which
was called with i believe point two
percent of the vote in
called faster than the new york city
mayoral race i think that's how fox news
called arizona i said did bob vote all
right we're gonna put it on the board
we're the only republican there everyone
will hate this who watches our shows
yeah they do great can we just make sure
that everyone despises us yeah cnn was
bending over backwards not to call
virginia last night yeah yeah yeah you
know what while we're doing it
put up a news max billboard behind me
[Laughter]
uh all right so we'll be talking about a
lot of this and i do want to hear from
you guys of course we are available on
rumble sorry we're late today we had to
import some big files uh and make sure
we're still checking on some counties in
new jersey yeah we wanted to be right
with the info so uh before we get to all
of that uh gerald a how are you i'm well
sir how are you doing good did you
recover from a four and a half hour
stream i did i did i i washed it down
with a victory drink last night after
virginia victory is it a wine virginia
oh some kind of special i thought
victory was a type of wine liquid no
well i mean sure you know because you're
an affected prick uh all right i was
going to ask how you are you know what
screw you how are you doing i washed it
down
with a nice old cup of bare foot by the
way don't use plastic glasses they melt
stop it with barefoot quarter black
garrett how are you
oh no
what oh jeez
he's tired from being disenfranchised
with the boat
he flew to new jersey just to be
disenchanted
what so disenchanted yes
you have ignored me at your own peril
what are you talking about i'm black
how are you sir it's a surprise i'm i'm
doing good yeah so excited about the red
wave yeah what red weave yeah red wave
hopefully it's uh from now on the red
wave always with wings right and uh all
right uh dave flanders
is at the catillion which wichita kansas
on november 11th oh and this weekend in
philadelphia how are you ahoy i'm good
please come out philly come out witchy
yeah come out give it a give david a red
wave there a little bit put a towel down
yeah please put a towel down is that
what
oh that's right the thing about the
cotillion in wichita kansas is it's in
his basement yes
that's correct that's
yes it is that's
a man cave really
yeah oh jeez uh so uh by the way if you
are watching this on youtube uh i'm
gonna ask you first off to hit that like
button okay
and i just want you to know
hit
the issue is uh this show is available
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
today obviously to start a little late
to get some election info correct we
don't want to have one of those calling
arizona fiascos but uh if you tune in
here on youtube and it's not here for
those who are watching on youtube go
over to rumble of course you can join
mug club where uh today we'll be doing
uh they don't make them like they used
to blaze and saddles edition
which of course very spicy i love it and
promo code fight like hell 20 off mug
club okay
now before we get to the election um
this is something which will undoubtedly
be uh false copyright struck on youtube
from the producers at colbert they've
been gunning for us for weeks every time
they don't like us in japan
if they do not like us in japan why well
it's stephen it's uh the people at cbs
did you know this dave the people at cbs
the producers and their lawyers use the
strict speech laws in japan to get our
videos that critique colbert banned in
japan and i think some places in south
carolina are these uh les moonves's
attorneys do you remember that cbs guy
yes i do had sex with everyone yes he
did against the will well he wanted to
leave them with a smile on their face
i'm just glad they're moral yeah money
in their pockets yeah i mean really this
is these are the people who banned it in
japan you're not there's not a pandemic
of people in japan
japan
japan
is a cool beer country
it looks first word it looks first world
but they'll still take a rake to poke
you onto the subway
that's not a matter well he was a camel
fan
[Laughter]
it's always really uncomfortable when
the guy shoves in japan have you seen
these where they shove them into the
subway yes but they put on their rising
sun bandana and they just tackle them
oh well all the time it's tradition i
did that in new york gym
you know have some soccer i've had too
much
amphetamine in front of citrine
[Laughter]
they're all gonna get sick yeah
cluttered in like that
i don't think that's all right let's uh
watch and react first to the wonderful
comedy coming from the left stephen
colbert is back with more vaccine
propaganda here we go dave
oh paw patrol patrol i have kids
sick gonna stay in bed today marshall
you realize this is a video call why are
you laughing yeah i do it's a track
marshall i meant to say i can't come in
because i'm taking my dog to the vet you
are a dog is this about your rabies shot
he's an anti-vaxxer i'm not taking it i
don't want my balls to swell up like
nicki minaj's cousin's friend's carrier
marshall it's kind of funny
yeah they're trying what have i been
licking
adventure bay needs your help you've got
to get vaccinated screw adventure bay
i'm not getting vaccinated what's the
worst that could happen nothing and now
it turns yeah there we go for a dog got
it mr finch he's got the rabies
that's pretty you know look here here's
the thing i appreciate that they're
trying yeah but how many writers 42 that
colbert just compare that to the uh
the braveheart intro that we just ran
yeah put a little effort you shut the
paw patrol dog i know you know what are
kids going to think about poor marshall
well i don't think kids are watching
colbert considering his median viewer is
74.
it's just someone who still left the tv
on after the jack lalanne juicer
commercial
why didn't they shoot the cop dog don't
they dislike cops i don't understand
that's true they also dislike atticus
finch that's true they say it's the
white savior complex so the point is
none of that works but it's still better
than
what was it
vaccine what was it uh
yeah it was almost as as good as that
yeah there's a bent needle which by the
way if you find one of those needles
discard it definitely don't share that
needle not the guy on the left yeah they
got the needle from rent
so
[Laughter]
and uh my question look that's a lot of
we're gonna get into
i i saw rent
yeah and i was just sitting there like
what you're saying they're coughing
you're like what is this you're all sick
you're all having sex with each other
and you know that they have aids and
you're you're using dirty needles
and you're not expecting aids and you're
singing yeah yeah that's the weird part
can somebody make a song about how not
to get aids because it's pretty i can
fix this whole situation yeah that's why
i just love team america just eight days
everyone has eight i want that seasons
of love to be a countdown clock as to
how many minutes they have left so i
know when to cork the champagne
we don't want to catch aids that's right
captain planet
foil was right what do you think let me
ask this you can comment below too
before we go there's some interesting
demographic shifts that have taken place
here just in one year but what do you
think before i get to it uh cause the
republican wave in places like virginia
and even if new jersey is too close to
call right now they're saying um
win lose or draw that's a big change
for new jersey so you need you need to
see that and of course we are going to
assume
of course that there have these are all
the safest and most secure elections in
our history ever and compare it to the
most secure election in our history with
donald trump so again the the the
demographics and the numbers that we're
using assume that those are uh
authoritative yeah yes are we good are
they i mean i think we're clear i think
everything is legit yes mm-hmm yes
what what what do you think you think
the dem do you think the democrats are
gonna pull the old scroogie in jersey no
come on please jersey has there ever
been any sort of crime in the new jersey
area the same the same state that has
managed to cover up for two decades that
cory booker is gay
he's gay no
reviving the rotary club so
this past week
oh is that what sorry elks lodge ah yeah
oh i need to get
is he okay i mean erection licks and
kisses yes it does
yes it really does too early guys i'm
sorry i just did paw patrol dave four
women
okay so paw
past week let's bring this to our uh do
we have the original clip uh yeah
okay so this is actually because we have
an exclusive yeah but for people who
haven't seen this the former vice
president uh embarrassed the united
states at the sea i mean i need to make
sure it's cop 26 climate summit because
i keep wanting to say copd well yeah
i just saw c3po yes
and stopped reading oh no he's falling
asleep again
yes that's the sound he makes so um
i am an effeminate british bot yes i am
a butt who likes to have sex with boba
fett
more charisma than your leader artu get
the astro glide
oh no
a doritos commercial to film
so three beeps means yes yes
zero beeps means
yes
no matter what you hear i don't know
what he speaks all i know is i'm going
in
man
yes yes yes yes yes
yes okay
so here's the video of joe biden and
they don't even address this the leftist
media this is why it's he's clearly
falling asleep and i don't even mean
like a cat nap this
should wake up with a beard here you go
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
[Music]
there's the first time
and i i guess i shouldn't apologize but
i do apologize for the fact the united
states uh
the last administration pulled out of
the paris accords and put
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump then you ain't
black now i didn't want to show you the
entire clip of him falling asleep
because it's long it's like nine minutes
he got into rem sleeping he was dreaming
it was an inception night for him yeah i
mean he was giving the hair a run for
his money well just getting passed by
turtles
growing up with a still skin beard slow
and steady wins the race no i think for
the former vice president's slow and uh
uh slow slow yeah slow slow
oh no
yes
yes oh wait i mean he's vulnerable
what do you think he dreams about like
he just sees a white light and then
wakes up yeah every single day everybody
it's too slow to get to it no davey
dreams about being president yes yes
that's true what it would be like if he
actually was he wakes up he's like oh
i had the most wonderful dream he sees
kamala you were there
[Laughter]
major is just major's just biting the
black mate
he's like ah and you were there shoot
him
hate that administration that's official
they do
all right so um this is actually i know
that uh uh uh he's always wearing an
earpiece too a lot of people know that
yeah and we do have our plants we do
some investigative journalism and we
have exclusive audio from the copd
climate summit where uh former vice
president joe biden fell asleep
okay hang in there mr former vice
president only one hour left
oh no
oh no not again okay uh sir wake up
sir wake up
okay thank god oh oh joe joe
joe wake up
joe wake up joe
wake up joe for the love of god wake up
all right do the thing
[Applause]
you're a disgrace to this country
[Applause]
uh mr former vice president we have a
problem the depends fit flex you
requested are on back order so i could
only order the protection plus but
they're only available in medium
no no no medium okay then i'll just
order the standard night defense but
you'll need to wear your boxers
that is an accurate depends order check
out the website
you think you just did research about
logs yeah
yeah i was dreaming about uh ants on a
log celery oh hello come on peanut
butter come on let's get right into my
breakfast
ah crunchy no smooth it's kinda calorie
negative
crunchy could kill me yeah gets caught
in my pouch
my gizzards
my kisses are filled with chunky peanut
butter
oh no his gizzards are full again we
must perform the heimlich
come on r2 i do it slowly
[Music]
[Laughter]
shut up don't tell anyone don't spoil it
yes all right more votes than anybody in
history steve or both in anybody in
history most popular
president in history without a doubt
81 million legitimate votes yeah i
believe his last count was 150 million
wow well it's oh recounts and more
mailing ballots
you know
oh i forgot the cooler yeah i'm glad we
went isn't it funny that if you stay up
until 2 a.m
you still don't see the vote switch no
in other words that would be a
conservative estimate like hey yeah you
know what i stayed up until 2am and i
feel pretty good that this is no no no
no
three and four a.m that's the magic
ticket fellas uh that's when the most
secure votes come in yeah i just always
remember as a kid i'd be like i don't
know i got my a hockey game or something
you know and i'm just like looking up at
the tv yeah and they had everything set
by like right like 9 00 p.m yeah well 9
30. well with the advent of you know all
these fun fancy computers we've gotten
worse at counting yeah somehow isn't it
amazing
i mean but basically by by like four
o'clock mondale was on a plane to
anywhere right yeah i lost yeah he's
like come on let's just i just voted in
my home midnight plane going yeah
and in his case belize
uh all right
so last night let's get into the uh the
recap here um the virginia governor race
was called for other republican glenn
you can this is a big deal in virginia
because virginia they've been saying has
been going increasingly
uh blue and the same thing obviously
with new jersey but the interesting
thing is some of the demographic shifts
as to why juncken won and uh it's it's
something that look i am going to
issue some harsh criticism here to the
people who actually need to use tampax
and always you know what i mean i'm not
uh i'm not without empathy thank you um
of course when uh the republican won and
it was called the leftist pundits were
uh
you know it was like they stared at the
ark of the covenant and the exit poll
showed that
which was interesting that the
coronavirus or the virus it was a very
low importance to many voters
which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching yes
continue calling them racists
for trump in this election per the exit
polls they're going 57
43 for mcauliffe that is not macro
that's issues with education being the
number one thing on the minds of these
voters that means that terry mcauliffe
lost a very specific messaging war on
race first of all it's not over um you
do have the grassroots folks out there
fighting for this on the democratic
party side the stakes are high
uh when this election is over virginia
we will know
have we seen the emergence of the delta
variant of trumpism
the delta variant of trump is another
one so clever same disease
that spreads a lot faster it can get a
lot more places
hey by the way uh just for people out
there if you guys can pitch in like with
hurricane harvey new jersey uh has a
supply chain shortage for uh printing
toner
stupidest thing
he was sitting there writing it was like
ralphie with his uh writing his paper
his term paper about wanting a red rider
he's like delta varian man that's great
i'm gonna ask wendy to go steady that's
so small i love how she said education
yeah i'm like because only white parents
which is code for no it's not is that
it's education we care about our kids no
no no please please let's let them
continue by all means continue accusing
the moms who are involved with their
children
of being racist yes that will sway them
and all the black moms out there that
just absolutely don't care about
education because it's code for white
supremacy oh which by the way going back
to the written house thing before we
move on with the the governorships yeah
i saw the left complaining we were
talking about this there was only one
black juror
uh why do you think that is
the prosecutor i guarantee you was
dismissing people of color yes faster
than they could come do you really think
that you are going to get black people
on that jury in that jury pool who are
going to be empathetic to a ginger
serial pedophile who repeatedly yelled
the n-word
for crying out you think they want to
snitch on that guy
coming up we got to get him out yeah
did cal written shoot black guys
no i didn't shoot black guys
no just at first that's what they told
you yeah oh well that's true because you
read the transcript you're like well you
said the n word obviously this is this
this wouldn't be a ginger pedophile that
wouldn't make any sense
so
uh soulless ginger soulless ginger well
maybe i guess that's what that gingers
in general all gingers yeah are soulless
see that's just bigoted yeah no it's
true i mean you haven't read i wouldn't
have read curves i wouldn't go around
advertising that quarter black carrot
okay i'm gonna grow a stash so virginia
this is important uh youncan flipped
chesapeake montgomery
norfolk counties from 2020. now keep in
mind this is not even a midterm yeah
so here's what's interesting there has
been a change notably what killed donald
trump he made gains with black voters he
made gains with latino voters uh he lost
suburban white women yeah so women look
this is a step in the right direction i
will say this a lot of conservative
women out there first
you need to you need to clean ranks you
do because a lot of these problems that
you see that women are facing now come
from feminism and come and i'm going to
do an extended segment on this also this
this this really these tentacles go into
their dating pool they go into their
home life they go into women's sports
now this all comes from uh leftist
feminism and guess what the chickens
have come home to roost you have men in
biological men and women's sports
because of women and feminism you have
radical agendas in school because of
women and feminism you have men who are
playing the dating game and not marrying
because of women and feminism they have
changed their expectations so much of
what they want from men and what they
want from society and guys still want
the same things that they wanted before
the sexual revolution to be clear and
this is a lot of women coming home to
use the term here saying oh wow i need
to have some control over what happens
with my children that's why education is
a big issue here and it's not just
critical race three which you say is
imaginary and these people are actually
living and presenting receipts with the
books and the curriculums it's also
their kids have been locked down
indefinitely their kids have been forced
to wear masks which do not come
without their own consequences and there
are a lot of people who flipped because
of that this is overreach from the
democrats so women out there
who are tired of it please men cannot
just like men cannot solve the problem
of biological men beating the hell out
of women in women's sports because all
men opposed it men and women's bathrooms
men opposed it men and women sports men
opposed it women overwhelmingly
supported it and you said you have a
penis you can't have an opinion so women
out there strong women we need you now
to use this momentum because women with
uh donald trump for example 38
is what he got
junkin got 47
hey that's nice uh white women with some
college or less trump got 56 percent
younkin got 75 percent that's 80. yeah
women with children trump got 43 percent
yunkan got 46 which actually surprised
me independent voters trump got 38
percent yunkan got 54 that's a big jump
that's a big jump and i'm not saying
that this means junkin is better than
donald trump by any means um what i am
saying is there has been a shift with so
much over i don't think we've ever lived
in a time
in the history of this country with more
monumental
life-altering changes in the past year
and most americans don't like it and
they see where it's going but by all
means please keep accusing these people
who voted for your folks before of being
racist yeah i think what they're seeing
too is that donald trump may have been
brash he may have come across as kind of
this caustic figure yeah but he wasn't
wrong that's the thing so somebody now
is presenting the message in a way that
you can actually tolerate and you're
seeing the decisions that he was trying
to keep us from having to go towards
right so he was trying to keep us from
doing these things you're seeing those
decisions now have consequences that's
what's happening right now and assuming
of course the most safe secure election
in history that these numbers are
correct yes i do think
to to be fair there was definitely some
trump fatigue even from republicans yes
and i think this shows you because you
know this is people said he was a
trumpist this shows you that the ideas
from donald trump and if donald trump
were to be more disciplined that these
ideas are way more popular now again
i've always said this about sort of
generation z and i was wrong but um
certainly you see it with a lot of other
people you know look at the baby boomers
and you see it even more with
millennials now they had for example
carter and reagan they had that contrast
and that's when you create a generation
of conservatives this is the we didn't
really have that contrast with george w
bush wasn't a conservative was a big
government sort of republican barack
obama right then you have but then you
have donald trump in the pandemic and
you have former vice president joe biden
there's a clear contrast now people are
saying this is the wrong direction it's
a repudiation of that um
this and this is a big deal education
it's not a dog whistle no it's an actual
it's a thing it's a thing that affects a
lot of americans and uh remember this
was where he lost the election remember
when mcauliffe said parents shouldn't be
able to have input or tell teachers what
to teach here you go and i'm not going
to let parents come into schools and
actually take votes out and make their
own decision
you vetoed it so
yeah my parents you stop the bill that i
don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach yeah um
uh first off even if you believe it you
don't say it that way
that's your children
you know you're the fastest way to piss
off women everyone here has a wife
tell her what she should do yeah
tell them how to be a mom right yeah
right yeah from a good guy should should
you do that you should the bed okay it
doesn't work with women i learned that
i've even learned to avoid that where i
go hey baby honey sweetie buttercup baby
i said it might be a better idea or it
may be more helpful if not ah
should use the 409 on that toilet pole
she's like a 60-minute special babe you
know i'm just saying it's gonna get you
in trouble every time so um well i just
yeah whatever
you got nothing 84 of virginians said
that parents should have at least some
input into what schools are teaching and
it's no surprise obviously that junk had
made some gains in heavily suburban
areas i mean this is the issue right
donald trump made gains with black and
latino voters those gains seem to be
holding steady and now suburban
suburban white suburban voters have
returned to the republican party and
now white suburban women which is new
that is new
and that's a good thing and so women i'm
going to ask you please women just
comment below if you're you know we
actually have a significant amount of
women who watch this show yeah i'm
actually surprised when i go through the
comments there's a ton of them in there
you know because generally speaking
women if you look at demographics for
any late night comedy shows it's made up
of largely young men yeah uh so i want
to know what you believe the solution is
or what what you think women can do to
continue this momentum this is a big
shift
why did women part ways
under the air of trump and why are they
coming back i have a penis so i can't
have an opinion
and also on this they the
lieutenant governor i believe also was a
republican a black female
one in virginia i know we go from
governor blackface to
yeah yeah you know she must be one of
those token lieutenant governor
she doesn't she's an uncle lieutenant
governor something like that
i think they also won the state
legislature in virginia it's not like
this this i think it was a lot of 50 in
the house of delegates right i don't
remember oh there's the side by side
with that trigger discipline
hey but you know what really someone
call her onto alec baldwin's next set we
don't care if she's union she'll
probably know if the gun has a bullet in
it you would think so right right wait
what do you say a bullet and i can't say
that because what's up
so look this is
this is the transgender policy critical
race theory loudoun county this is
important remember this is one where uh
girl was raped and there was another
girl who was sexually assaulted by boy
and a skirt what are you gonna do now
youtube boy to skirt who fooled enough
people to take advantage of the
transgender bathroom policy loudoun
county donald trump lost that county by
25 juncken won it by 10.5
that's a 30 point am i doing the math
right ish 30 point split
someone call choi we'll have him do it
yeah he's just in the other room yelling
the answer yes
what's wrong he said he's not a man do
you see that switch yeah it's a huge
switch so we talked about we talked
about you know the suburbs right and we
talked about getting out of the rural
areas right suburbs that's a surprise a
little bit in some of these cases but
some of these counties like the cities
the switch is massive yeah you don't
even have to win those counties you just
have to take 20 30 000 votes well and
flip them and that's what he did and
that's what we'll get to when discussing
new jersey in a little bit because a lot
of people were surprised i believe
atlantic county in new jersey went for
uh the italian name that i can't
pronounce the non-murphy republicans
and uh yeah yeah that's that's great
repelling mosquitoes
sorry one one quick point on this young
he lost by ten point five oh he lost my
time
same thing he did because i was going to
say he did lose uh fairfax county but by
29 as opposed to trump losing by 41.
that that's massive oh yeah so wait a
minute you're telling me you're right
yeah i misread that completely i hit
that admonish button oh how the hell did
i get that one wrong
i deserve it
admonish me in the comment section
i'm gonna ratchet down the spike garter
right so you're telling me that he did
better with independence significantly
better he did better with women yep
white women suburban whatever women
period speaking of white women that's a
big trend today under share
hey
nice what if that were actually why i
should share and homosexuals
why right there between her fans are
mainly white women and homosexuals
they're entirely homosexuals
i criticize
almost a man on twitter said you will
never accomplish as much as share you
will never accomplish all this and i
hand to god sent me a picture tweeted me
a picture of his share wall oh boy oh so
he's sane yeah yeah
he's just sitting on a white horse wants
to wear cher's skin like a suit oh yeah
he's mel gibson
has
no i mean so he so we're doing better
and then we're doing better in democrat
strongholds yes counties so yeah there
was a 10 point 12 points almost made up
in fairfax county um
anyway there's a whole bunch of these
that have happened they won like i said
lieutenant governor attorney general
elections
and this is not just by the way it's not
just virginia this has happened all over
the country so in uh minnesota yeah it
was in minneapolis voters rejected a
ballot measure to defund the police no
remember the city council
i believe was i don't remember which
city council was in minneapolis if they
didn't know as minneapolis or st paul
they voted to defund the police nobody
cares about saint paul yeah did
something happen yeah yeah no
what
and this is something interesting too i
want to get to new jersey
quickly because we have to assume safe
and secure
which then begs the question safe and
secure why the flip at 3am
so
and i tweeted out yesterday i am going
to bed of course not expecting a vote
flip now uh
it's murphy citarelli i hope ciatarelli
ciabatta rally i don't care i don't
really no offense you got to say this
yeah
you're like hey come on so joey
citarelli
it's too close to call yeah and they're
saying well the because the mail-in
votes
and essay the votes we're going to get
to from essex county these are these are
all going to be of course uh murphy and
so he'll probably win here's the thing
about that
um they're basing that on projections
with new jersey not on the performance
so just like with transgender bathroom
policies or critical race three right
the democrats their strategy is don't
believe you're lying eyes and lioneers
yeah don't believe what's going on in a
school library don't believe what's
going on in school classroom right now
they're saying don't believe what you're
seeing across new jersey where the
results have come in in distinctly blue
counties our projections say that at 3am
essex county is going to flip the race
here's the thing murphy's been
underperforming in other blue counties
so for example he won atlantic county in
2017 by 12 points he's losing now by 12
points
wow um this is there's a big shift when
you look at a lot of these uh you look a
lot of these counties in new jersey so
why would you assume that there's going
to be such a wide gap in essex county
that's the issue that i have and
something else remember this is
something uh uh dave you were covering
because you're from detroit you were
covering this live when they they called
wayne county for detroit they called
detroit wayne county for trump here's
the thing before that you can go back to
all our live streams and this is the
value of doing a live stream right
everyone else edits it and they try and
make themselves look better afterwards i
just had to admonish myself
it happens you saw us in real time
living through it and before the
election they all said now we expect the
mail-in votes to be overwhelmingly biden
yeah the night of the election in
detroit this was not new information
having taken that into account in wayne
county they still ran the numbers and
said it's such an overwhelming gap that
even with the mail-in ballots uh they
called it for trump yes they did
left-wing media called it for trump yes
so it was a sure thing and then but
people forgot that there was a cooler of
camera equipment yes yeah and that has
allegedly the real weapon secure red
wagons listen i didn't say no i said a
camera equipment hey you know what they
brought in they brought in an auto focus
lens and 160 000 votes switched listen
we're on to you let's go brandon people
yeah okay yeah yeah exactly
people horrible
let's go brandon think about that for a
second so they knew that said even with
the mail in ballots they're calling it
for donald trump and then afterwards
when it switched they said oh the mail
in ballots you already called it knowing
the mail-in ballots that's what's
happening right now similarly they're
they're going all right well look uh
look okay well oh my gosh that's a
20-point difference from 2017 here uh to
republicans in atlantic county no one
thought that would go there are a bunch
of other counties which i'm sure we can
find we don't have all the numbers in
but significantly the democrat was
underperforming projections but they're
saying our projections for essex county
you know that's going to be so
overwhelmingly murphy that
you know it's in the bag for murphy
right no no i don't trust you and i also
look can we have a due date
we have a due date on the votes
deadlines
i mean how little do democrats think of
their voting base like wow hold on a sec
people have time we have to postdate it
uh you know uh through uh black friday
wait wait wait hold on why wow people
don't what what what they have time to
be licking stamps or no stamps licking
envelopes come on so there's some really
interesting things and i'm not going to
get into how about before midnight yeah
yeah we'll treat it like gizmo from
gremlins yes exactly yes and don't get
the balance
don't get the ballots wet yes you don't
want to
it smears and then it says biden yeah
would you like a vote
so in the new jersey race right now
there's some there's some interest in a
particular county it's either bergeron
or bergen county i don't know if there's
a second hour
the thank you uh at midnight the uh
county clerk's office uh bergen thank
you the county clerk's office
basically said look 100 of the precincts
have reported in the republican had i
think 51 and changed percent the
democrat had 47. everybody woke up this
morning and that number had switched yes
and so there was a lot of concern now
they're saying basically i don't know
100 of the precincts have have reported
in but we haven't counted the mail-in
ballots
don't say 100 and so now it goes back to
like we have cnn with saying that that's
not what you do
there's only 86 percent and i'm like
guys
look at the and we'll dig into this a
little bit further i know there's a lot
of people out there with interest into
finding out what's going on there if if
you're trying to come off of 2020 and
make sure that you put people in kind of
a place of comfort with their election
system in a state you don't do something
like that you come up with like all of
the precincts for in-person voting have
come in we haven't counted the mail-in
ballots yet but this is the whole point
that we talked about
i was looking at numbers live on our
live stream of donald trump he was
outperforming himself yes from 2016. i
wasn't even close and a lot of these
things and i kept doing the math and i'm
like this is insane like he's he's
kicking his own ass i know
he's kicking his opponent and then he's
yeah exactly and so that's you're not
instilling confidence in people when you
do stuff like that so we're going to
let's just blame them for mistrust in
the institutions right that's what
happens the left goes i can't believe
it's the problem you know sewing all
this doubt is republican lies no no no
no no no we were following your sites
and your news streams and you switched
it we weren't watching fox news no and
we were following what you said circa
2016 2017 2018 about the election system
and it's potential problems that maybe
could possibly be fixed it in 2019. the
issue is this if you can say 100 and
then say no we didn't mean 100
if you can say all right well it needs
to be by election day sorry we meant two
we posted two weeks from election day if
you can say all right we're going to
create this new unconstitutional law in
pennsylvania as it relates to uh
mail-in voting if you can do all of that
you cannot expect americans to have
trust in the integrity of election
institute the
you know this was to be so i have to be
careful banned on youtube when i called
someone in nevada called an official and
said this is an address this is where we
lasered in on one this is one address
this person is not there
let's say that you guys got this wrong
how do you how do you switch it if you
find something yeah how'd he fix it
he said
there is no process for that
so you tell me where's the
accountability where's the oversight by
the way last night a lot of pipes broke
dave
what
i think it was 100 percent of 86 percent
yeah that makes sense
i don't know what you can say on youtube
that's what sucks that sucks
here's all i know i drove around detroit
to certain addresses
and uh you know
it seemed fishy
because there was a man who voted named
fishy yes john fishy he lived in a field
yeah yeah well there was a result the
idiom
voted twice from a koi pond oh weird
well i mean in michigan that wasn't
there a county there was a county race
that was flipped right they accidentally
gave it to the democrat and then it oh
sorry i'd say that well
wayne county itself is going to always
it's going to usually be democratic
yesterday a democrat won but a lot of
that is
white and black that is that is where
that does exist still in this country
and the fact that uh dugan who's a white
guy took it for the third time
is kind of shocking well you know what
though can someone uh bring it up we'll
do talk about you know we'll talk about
this on mug club
can researchers bring it up i've talked
about this before i know the sources in
front of me donald trump
significantly outperformed you know in
major cities with black voters yeah in
urban areas with black voters with
latino voters in nearly all major cities
outside of
i think six yeah outside of like detroit
philadelphia phoenix so in other words
in seattle outperformed with plans
in los angeles out performed with you
know with with blacks compared to
projections and then uh detroit whoa boy
he really screwed the pooch at uh 4 a.m
so my favorite before we move off of
this my favorite result right now
was seattle uh that last night they
elected a city attorney a republican oh
in seattle by the way that the if if if
we had really if wisconsin was the place
that this was going to happen if
minneapolis was like the epicenter this
was the second one of the defund the
police you know right chazz i was going
to say chaz must have not showed up to
vote no he's shooting trump voters in
the face and shooting up yeah are they
making him marry courtney love yes
i just loved it i'm like oh this is
great yeah i love seeing republicans
just like put it in your
wow
oh well beautiful place if it wasn't for
the people yes for all of the crap right
in the middle yeah yeah also kitchen
get your own slogan keep seattle weird
uh okay austin uh we've had that like a
minute for a while you get off the plane
and it just smells like spoon metal
cooking
[Music]
[Laughter]
i did see that in chop oh yeah it was
like oh you absolutely did i did
absolutely yeah
good job
i tried it
that's that's where you guys i got a i
got like an email saying you guys didn't
check into your hotel that we booked oh
yeah because because they were being too
aced by socialists with guns which we
were going to check into our hotel and
there was literally just
hobos everywhere taking shits and doing
heroin and all kinds and we were like
not gonna stay here no i was i was
panicking i thought that they just
didn't make her they were lost yeah we
thought you were
it's a i mean we gave we gave him a
one-star hotel right that's the in their
contract yeah it's one one
breakfast yeah okay a breakfast in an
autonomous zone yeah well it's called
the cotillion and it's in dave's
basement it was this yes it was a
seattle steamer
sitting there my basement i have several
basements
you go right neighborhood you get a
basement 50 60 bucks a month yep no
you're absolutely right it's true
no house above you hey we need dave to
have his own show like susie ormond
[Laughter]
can i afford this basement yes yes
but what about in the yes
all right so
do it that would be great just to have
one of those home renovation shows but
it's just a pervert in the basement it's
just what do you want
what would you like uh would you let's
say no that's the home of the
redecorated flipper like would you like
a rustic look would you i don't care if
i see the rivets i just want to make
sure no one can hear anything
that's a lot of mirrors put a drain in
the floor is that a well well it's a pit
there's not water in it yeah there's no
water or anything like that wait a
second what's that sound you hear from a
closet oh no this was not consensual
that would have been a perfect sos if
not for the flatulent sound damn it
leave him alone you share a gunshot and
then it's like let me show you the rest
of this basement
that's not murder it's a robot yeah all
right speaking hey speaking of of uh sex
trafficking uh elon musk exposed not
elon musk
he exposed
he brought to the attention of a lot of
people it's one of those things where
it's like ah okay at a certain point
yeah you can't really parody alex jones
anymore no brought to the attention of
people the uh um the sex trafficking
that occurred at the hands of the un so
let me get into this first i can explain
to you the context uh and what the media
did cover as it related to world hunger
and what the media did not cover as it
relates to the un admittedly
uh being involved in
basically uh sex trafficking for food in
third world countries so on monday the
un world food program director david
beasley
appeared on um
he appeared on cnn to uh demand that
billionaires
here's the thing more money you're
asking those billionaires who are going
to space
the likes of elon musk and jeff bezos to
help
are they helping
the governments are tapped out
and this is why and this is when
that the billionaires need to step up
middle age richard drummond bases six
billion dollars working class
people i thought that dennis was working
it's not complicated yes that's dennis
wolfe we need the billionaires to pay uh
so i don't know why they won't pay you i
don't know why they won't pay it no
me and you're the only person who knows
what we're talking about that guy was
amazing he was so funny i watched it
when i was like that might be in one of
my top five albums when we do that uh
tomorrow or monday so cnn then wrote an
article title this is the u.n demanding
billionaires pay to solve world two
percent of elon musk's wealth could help
solve world hunger so the director of un
food scarcity organization now elon
responded and this is what was covered
then i'll tell you what was not covered
and it relates to child rape
if he responded if a wfp can describe on
this twitter thread exactly how six
billion will solve world hunger i will
sell tesla stock right now and do it but
it must be open source accounting so the
public sees precisely how the money is
spent i'm doing an impression of my
friend peter from belgium i don't know
what yeah that works that's close
dead on then beasley responded saying i
can be in the next i can be on the next
flight to you throw throw me out if you
don't like what you hear
so they call me the beezer yeah they
come in they be this was no boating
accident
so
musk here's the thing everyone covered
that
and the point that musk was making and
this is the guy by the way who's
responsible this is the ultimate irony
for the ecological revolution with
electric cars which by the way are worse
for the environment i don't care they go
fast
the point is you guys loved him and now
you hate him and he's just saying
look the un wastes money yeah you are
it's the same if you believe that it's
the government's job on anything you
believe it's the government's job to
house all the homeless you believe it's
the government's job to provide welfare
to provide free health care provide free
internet like in germany where it's a
human right all these things you also
have to go along with the premise that
the government is fundamentally capable
of performing it my issue is not with
climate change that it's getting a
little balmy my issue is believing that
this five-page
proposed bill the green new deal would
actually work let's assume we were
actually in an armageddon scenario or
deep impact scenario you really think
the guy falling asleep at the cop26
climate summit is the one who should be
helming the ship at fixing it so that's
the point elon musk was making and he
drove the point home by pointing out
dropping really a nuclear bomb here an
article about u.n officials forcing
african children to perform oral sex for
food and he just said what uh what uh
what happened here
that's all he said oh i'm sorry i was
like this you
is that a crime it you well it's a
little murky on the rule book okay well
well i just want to make sure the laws
changed at 3am they weren't hungry dave
look i got a lot of rice
and a full bag
terrible
sorry i i
understand the euphemisms uh so
this is the thing just so you know this
isn't some all references are available
louder with crowder that's just so gross
it is so gross but it's really terrific
the link is in the description don't
take my word for it you n chair marie de
chan however you guys say it in english
deschamps i don't know fish amps uh here
she is addressing the report and then i
will read from you details about the
official
report child sex trafficking
i don't want to say on behalf of the u.n
the u.n is the reason for it they
screwed up weather was deliberate or not
not in the business of questioning
motives
kids in africa were sodomized for food
because of the u.n here you go this
results in a situation where documents
pass from
inbox to inbox
where anyone can think someone else will
take responsibility
in our view
this was a serious failure
not only did this show
abuse of authority by senior officials
on an individual basis
but it also highlights deficiencies at
an institutional level yeah it's the
abuse of authority that uh is the real
crime here oh no wait the sodomy of a
young child that's what that's
yeah yeah that seems worse i don't think
he was asking do you have the authority
no i think he was more thinking i'm
being raped yeah why did they randomly
cut to her handing someone a paper i
don't know looks like i do stuff around
the office
it looks like she went and asked for the
pharah faucet hairdo but it wasn't long
enough she's like here i made a crude
drawing of what they do yes exactly
please uh you know we'll put it in the
virginia school curriculum what the
hell's the difference yeah why not
in 2016 the u.n published this article
uh and by the way the report also stated
that uh 2016. oh i'm sorry that that
makes it better yeah
uh one child was orally and anally raped
to be clear and uh the u.n published
this article saying uh that ban says he
holds all senior u.n officials
responsible for addressing sexual
exploitation or abuse
okay
well that's gonna that's gonna put the
fear of god in them yeah now u.n
officials i'm gonna hold you responsible
and there will be an internal
investigation uh at the hands of other
u.n officials hey stop having sex with
that kid we have to do an investigation
he's going to get over here the minute
he's done
this is his grace you're in trouble
trust me that guy makes a mean mac and
cheese there is uh
there's a pot of gold the u.n was just
the u.n was just the the the tech
workers from to catch a predator showing
up with you know half a foot long from
subway
[Laughter]
i was just gonna talk to them that's
what he said he said we would talk in uh
uh well where'd you meet him chat room
messenger pigeon just the spokesperson
from subway yeah
i love it i love it when the un does you
know like a resolution or something oh
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
you guys remember you know when that
small country uh invaded this other
small country oh russia taking literally
taking crimea from the ukraine no and
having a shadow war with them do you
remember so the the un is usually all of
its power and wonder did a resolution in
2014 and i'm like oh okay so maybe
something happened no nothing happened i
was reading another article in 2020 and
i had to do a double take because
they're like with the code 19 pandemic
and the same article and then two
paragraphs later uh we issue the same
resolution that we have right
what and by the way this is an example
of years later where the left will just
try and get think that your gas light
you right you're crazy where we're all
we're saying the same thing for example
where donald trump would go up and say
listen we should not be a part of the un
okay and people go yeah can you believe
it joe biden he says he wants to
withdraw from the u.n come on well with
the context that they were trafficking
children for sex
also let me give you some more context
as to why the u.n is useless to be clear
nato had a purpose however other
countries aren't paying their fair share
the u.n has no purpose and other
countries aren't paying their fair share
how do you expect these people to care
about human rights when it includes
china and cuba
you ever heard some term you're only as
strong as your weakest link in this case
you're only as strong as your communist
fascist [ __ ] is that is it time for
iran to be the head of the human rights
council again and you and is it their
turn again yeah our new uh our new u.n
guidelines are it's just fatwas that's
rough salman rushdie i hope you have uh
a cotillion lots of elevators to tall
buildings being put in use i see 2020
u.n condemned israel 17 times
the rest of the world only six
because nothing bad happened to the rest
of the world in 2020 by the way i picked
al jazeera as the source there
deliberately on purpose
uh
it's funny is they love to criticize the
united states for racism and police but
20 of their funding comes from the
united states yeah 20
for context china 12
japan 8.5 percent uk 4.6 percent russia
2.4 percent two yeah well russia's not
going to buy into them they got a lot of
gas they're trying to steal i got a lot
of bread yeah oh my god i'm sure putin's
going to get right on that like oh i'm
sorry check must have been lost in mail
with ballots
i stabbed someone with tip to poison
umbrella yes that's it would you like
some tea don't worry it's still bubbling
yes
enjoy hell
by the way anybody who condemns the
united states for racism hasn't traveled
no just go to europe there's a reason in
japan
you're allowed to refuse tenants who
aren't japanese it i mean it is absolute
mockery it just shows that you haven't
done any research at all every single
soccer match in europe the largest sport
in the world they have no racism bans
they have no racism signs do you see
that in the united states no because
it's not nearly as bad racism we don't
recognize racism in other countries so
for example the japanese and the chinese
if you look at the level of cruelty now
we don't understand because for example
me and the people you'll see for example
in the package in an area of south
dallas black americans we look
much more different to the average
untrained eye than a japanese and a
chinese person but we have a lot more in
common so it's it's it's not yeah
something other than racism because the
japanese believed they were the superior
rays right they wanted this perfect sort
of pan-pacific race of people and the
chinese felt the same way about the
japanese this is the issue people don't
understand americans like well like
like america very open-minded country
open to people of all walks of life like
how about a black guy
oh
i said people yes i said
we lisa
read the petrino lines
[Laughter]
so americans america is a melting pot
that's the reason why we get along with
each other and every other country is a
bit racist because they don't have that
the various cultures i mean
japan was for the longest time based on
a racial identity absolutely china based
on a racial identity the nordic
countries based on a racial identity
most of south america based on a racial
identity the united states was not that
now i know that what what you will say
here you have the identitarians and
you're right largely western white
european people who found this country
because the values were shared even
among the first ways of sort of italians
caf irish catholics jews polish people
uh and i understand that you're saying
that's very different from someone today
from say el salvador but we weren't a
nation if you look at our decrees
founded on preserving or or or
forwarding a specific race of people
that's not the case well in the country
in japan it's in the language too right
if you're a japanese person you're a
nihonjin if you're anyone else you're a
gaijin
well come on not everyone who's on not
japanese is a female prostitute but it's
a lot like gringo no i don't know what
that i don't know what i thought i just
meant white people is it yeah
i think it's derogatory isn't it oh i
mean i don't care if you call them
someone please tell me so i know when to
be offended
well i needed to go as long as they pay
me to drive them over the border i don't
give a rat's patootie what they i hear
gringo i i get a little hungry
i like the word gringo get the gringo
with mel gibson i like that too by the
way uh they condemned the united states
for moving the embassy to jerusalem
something that donald trump promised he
would do and did and in 2020 the uns uh
keep in mind this is also what
elon musk was calling him to the map for
uh their world food program in french
international received nearly 8.5
billion in funding oh still lots of
hungry people are there still yeah i
because the tweet said 66 billion
billion and we could solve it look how
much money from the ion goes to hungry
people in africa versus versus you know
for sodomy versus say like the christian
children's fund or samaritan's purse
remember samaritan's purse went into
liberia when there was ebola with a 50
death rate right so keep in mind this is
the thing people don't understand that
the most effective and the most
significant charitable institute
institutions that have ever existed ever
in the history of mankind are
it does not include any international
governing body of any kind it is the
american evangelical church period not
even close
may not like them
you may think of them as carrie's mom
but the point is they're doing a lot
more than the child rapists at the u.s
did the christian college fund that was
the beard guy with the fly christian
children's fund yeah yeah yeah is that
did they do a lot though they did well
there's a new now they renamed it and i
think probably to get rid of christian
but well i don't know or just have the
guy walking through who looks very full
yeah yeah look at all these you know
what's really going to resonate is santa
claus yes and he looks like he's already
eaten the cookies right yeah and the
deer's carrots walking through with a
foot long sub just being like look at
these kids with the fly but i'm really
hungry you to help me feed them because
i mean i'm oh i couldn't eat another
bite someone throw this away all right
are you ready this is take three all
right i'm gonna get it right i don't get
these flies that's gross get them away
from my sandwich let's i throw pieces of
bread at them like pigeons yeah well not
today's bread
i'm not wasteful yesterday's bread
they'll eat anything these kids
that's basically what the u.n does and
rape so uh do we i was going to ask do
we want to run this pack do we want to
run it on mug club because i know we're
going over time
um yeah we could okay so let me explain
this to people by the way if you're
watching on rumble smash that rumble
button smash it
uh and if you're watching on youtube
consider watching on rumble
this is something that is
it does come down to and we're going to
go we have a package where i'm on
location and it's like 20 minutes with
people talking about covid and masks and
vaccines
they try and label you
this is something very very clear an
election denier a climate denier right
these are terms they'll they'll claim
they'll accuse you of being a science
denier and then you can also add other
umbrella terms like
racist dog whistles homophobia
transphobia
let's walk through that for a second
what does climate denier mean and i i do
want to hit this here before we leave so
i'm going to hit the stupid button thing
um
because
if you buy into the premise well then
you buy into all that wholesale and
women specifically women who voted
against trump are not buying that
anymore climate denier what does that
mean let me explain to you what it means
for me and if you look at the videos
that i've released and we're going to do
an entire episode on climate change
predictions there was a meme being
shared with something like 50
predictions and there were no sources
and i always
i always see these come across my
timeline and i'm skeptical
and every single one was true
so um oh no i don't even want to go to
see
so
let's go through okay you're a climate
denier what does that mean
let's say you believe in climate change
can you still be climate tonight
according to the left absolutely that's
irrelevant let's say you believe in
climate change and you believe that
mankind is
even largely responsible can you still
be labeled the climate tonight
absolutely that's irrelevant
let's say you believe in climate change
you believe that humankind is largely
the cause of it
but you just don't believe that the
federal government or the un
can actually do anything to tackle it
sort of like world hunger climate denier
that's all it takes all it and then they
say why don't you trust your
institutions why don't you trust the
scientific institutions when it comes to
climate change and they tell you this
bogus number that 97 of scientists agree
which we've already debunked it's not
true then they say all right so you're
climate tonight why are you an election
denier the big lie hold on a second
um
will they concede that you are not an
election denier if you believe in the
united states of america and you believe
that we have had largely free and fair
elections throughout our history
yeah of course they can still label you
that that's irrelevant will they accuse
you of being an election denier or a pro
a proponent of the big lie
if you accept for example that not only
have most elections been free and fair
but you even believe that joe biden
likely won the popular vote in this last
election of course they can still label
you a big lie uh proponent that's
irrelevant
they label you a big lie proponent and
an election denier if you say most
elections are free and fair i think joe
biden won i do think along with a
majority of americans at this point
that some of the anomalies
probably need to be addressed and you
can't change the rules right before an
election and i think this favored the
democrats boom you're an election denier
okay now we go to uh you're a science
denier hold on a second
will they label you a science denier if
you believe that covid19 is a real virus
of course they'll still label you that
it's that's irrelevant to the point will
they still label you a science denier if
you say covid is a real thing and we
need to fast track a vaccine of course
also label you with kobe denier that's
exactly what donald trump and most
people in america believed will they
still label you
a cova denier and believe me i'm sp i'm
speaking to the democrats here i believe
i understand that it might seem as
though this is uh repetitive to you but
democrats believe that their audiences
are idiots so hopefully this will reach
a few of them so you believe that covet
is a real thing you believe we need to
fast track a vaccine um
and you even believe that the vaccine
today
makes sense for most people just not
everybody of course also label you a
science scenario it doesn't matter
that's irrelevant to the point will they
still label you a science denier if you
say cova 19 is real we need a fast
traffic vaccine i believe the vaccine is
good for a lot of people but i also
believe that we should have robust
scientific studies of currently
available treatments so it's not a
one-size-fits-all
approach boom science denier what if you
didn't even say that said i believe in
the vaccine i don't believe ivermectin
works i believe there are no treatments
available i just don't think
i've gone along with all of it
i just don't support lockdowns and
canceling kids schools boom you're a
science and i along with by the way half
of europe so my point is this if they
claim you're a science denier you're an
election denier proponent of the big lie
you're a climate denier just explain
your position how much more rational it
is than any of the [ __ ] they're
peddling like oh essex county is going
to flip all of new jersey at 3 a.m and
wear it proudly i guess at that point
we're all climate deniers science
deniers and proponents of the big lie if
you at all are skeptical of
authoritative institutions with people
who've never held a private job in our
economy all of us are deniers and you
know what i think it's about time to
deny deny deny tonight i think it's a
good thing i don't think that progress
for the sake of progress is always the
best the credit card's been maxed out
it's time for it to be declined don't
let them tar and feather you that way
and women women specifically the women
who changed the virginia election
and changed certainly the outlook of the
new jersey this is this is a time where
your voice is clearly being heard
democrats just like with black voters
took them for granted
thought that you were all voting with
your vaginas you know
using the lever
and then playing a harmonica with it the
point is they thought that's how you
voted and now you said you know what we
care more in virginia uh about our
children's education we don't just
believe in abortion up until and
including birth hey we can think for
ourselves have those
conversations with everyone you know
don't let them label you a self-loathing
woman or a cold [ __ ] because you don't
believe that the government can solve
the problem of education in this country
you know how i know they're wrong
because moms say that they are wrong all
right let's go we're going to roll this
package when we get here to mug club
youtube thank you very much everyone
there smash the like button piss off i'm
gonna go find some [ __ ] to talk to
[Music]